يمكن أن تكون الخنافس التي تخرج من
الصبار يمكن أن تكون البول الجاف لبقرة
الحشرات الصغيرة التي تنمو على شجرة بلوط
، قطعة من الرصاص مغموسة في الخل ،
إنه لأمر مدهش حقًا
أننا في جامعة هارفارد خارج
مجموعة الصبغات القصيرة
جزيء صغير جدًا من مادة
ملونة يتم مزجها بوسط تجليد
يعطي الصباغ لونه ،
وقد تم تجميع مجموعة الصبغة القسرية
على مدار عدة عقود ،
ولدينا حوالي 2500 صبغة ولدينا الكثير
من الألوان غير العادية والنادرة جدًا.
هل أعتقد أن أحد
الأصباغ التي تم تسميتها بشكل غير عادي تسمى
دم التنين ، فهي لا تأتي من
التنانين ، فهي تأتي من راتان بالمز
وتعطي صبغة حمراء ساطعة للغاية ، ويتعلق
الجانب غير المعتاد من المومياء
بمصدرها بدلاً من اللون نفسه
وهذا يأتي من المومياوات المصرية
وهو الراتنج الذي يتم وضعه على الجزء
الخارجي من الضمادات ، وأعتقد أن
أندر لون لدينا هو في الواقع
كرة كاملة من الأصفر الهندي
وهي صبغة مصنوعة من السنة الجافة
ومن أبقار تتغذى فقط على
أوراق المانجو
إذا كنت تبحث عن عمل فني
وتريد أن تفهم ما هو أصلي
وما هو الترميم ،
فستأخذ عينة صغيرة  من الصباغ وتحليلها ، فإن
الكثير من الأصباغ سامة بالفعل ،
لذا لا ترغب في التعامل مع الأصباغ
ثم الخروج لتناول الغداء ،
فهناك لون أخضر يسمى الزمرد
الأخضر به مركز للزرنيخ يمكننا
استخدامه لمعرفة ما إذا كان هناك شيء ما
حقيقي أم لا ، سيقول الناس أن هذا من قبل
فنان معين ويمكننا أن ننظر إلى
المواد المستخدمة ونقرر ما إذا كانت
هذه المواد متاحة
خلال حياة الفنانين إذا لم يكن كذلك ،
فعلينا أن ننظر إلى من قد رسم
تلك الصورة.  لا يمكنني اختيار مفضل شخصي
هناك ، إنه مثل طلب اختيار
طفل مفضل ، ولن يشعر 2400 الآخر
بأنه مهمل
[موسيقى]